je lui demanderais bonjour merci d'être
en direct sur rt france alors tout
d'abord pourquoi le projet c'est celle
des tilles jugé incompatible avec le
droit européen
tu montes c'est un arrêt très
intéressant que dieu cj vu hier il
éteint et plutôt invalides par la
commission européenne dans la mesure où
droit américain ne respecte les
principes imposé par commission
européenne et le fameux art gp dès le
règlement général sur la protection des
données
dowd sur le fait les renseignements
américains de pouvoir aller consulter
les données personnelles des
utilisateurs européens lorsque celles ci
sont transférées aux entreprises
américaines
alors la décision a donc été applaudir
par les défenseurs des libertés ouvre
également une période d'incertitude pour
les entreprises justement quel type
d'entreprise est concerné par cette
invalidation
alors finalement toutes les entreprises
qui utilisent le transfert des données
personnelles aux états unis donc on peut
penser tout de suite aux gaffes a bien
entendu les les grosses entreprises
américaines qui peuvent utiliser les
données personnelles des citoyens
européens
mais ça va au delà de ça des coûts
d'utiliser un serveur basé aux états
unis par exemple pour une société
française ou européenne
vous avez vous avez besoin vous aviez
besoin potentiellement du privacy feed
pour transférer vos données aux états
unis alors qu'on a la possibilité
d'avoir malgré l' invalidité du privacy
field les clauses contractuelles types
contractuelles types qui nous permettent
quand même de continuer le transfert
entre les états unis et l'europe
quel impact cette décision
à voir notamment dans les relations
commerciales entre les états unis et
l'union européenne
alors ça peut refroidir effectivement
les échanges commerciaux entre les
parties l'idée plutôt maintenant de ne
plus se reposer sur ce préavis fils qui
est humain dans invalides mais de
négocier des contrats de transfert de
données entre les partenaires
commerciaux aux états unis et en europe
est-ce que vous pensez que cette
décision peu forcé justement les
américains revoir leur législation
c'est effectivement une éventualité eu
une sorte de petit rejet donc un
texte uniquement pour la californie en
matière de protection des données qui
pourraient se rapprocher de notre
législation européenne
mais on n'a pas encore d'actes qui
couvrirait la protection des données
personnelles sur l'ensemble du
territoire américain et il est possible
que les américains développent cette
législation dans les mois ou années à
venir et de bonheur et merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat en droit de
l'informatique et de la propriété
intellectuelle